[Música]
al menos 11 personas perdieron la vida y
20 permanecen desaparecidos tras el paso
de un ciclón por el sur de Brasil al
menos 3000 personas han tenido que ser
evacuadas en 40 municipios Pues el
fenómeno provocó deslizamientos
inundaciones y daños a infraestructuras
ampliamos desde Río
Argentina registra un alza de precios de
alimentos del 117% En comparación con
junio 2022 y sin aumento equiparable en
los salarios la desesperada Situación ha
llevado de numerosas personas a
sobrevivir con comida que desechan los
mercados
el turismo es un importante rubro del
producto interno bruto de Costa Rica en
el norte del país los indígenas maleku
reclaman su parte de los beneficios de
esta actividad desarrollada en sus
tierras ancestrales que consideran
sagradas
Bienvenidos a este informativo con las
noticias más relevantes del continente
americano soy Valentina Torres Sánchez y
es un gusto acompañarlos damos inicio en
el sur de Brasil una zona fuertemente
afectada por el paso de un ciclón que ha
dejado al menos once fallecidos y 20
desaparecidos en los últimos días la
defensa civil explicó que más de 3000
personas han tenido que evacuar unos 40
municipios del estado de Río Grande del
sur donde se han registrado
deslizamientos inundaciones y daño de
infraestructuras valerías acone
corresponsal de France 24 nos dio más
información sube el número de muertos y
desaparecidos en el sur de Brasil por
casa de un ciclón extra Tropical que ha
causado muchos destrozos se trata de un
fenómeno climatológico caracterizado por
fuertes rachas de viento de hasta 100
kilómetros por hora y por Fuertes
lluvias es un fenómeno que suele ocurrir
más en regiones como Asia Estados Unidos
o Europa Pero últimamente estamos viendo
en Brasil con cada vez frecuencia este
tipo de ciclones de momento hay cerca de
3.000 personas que tuvieron que ser
evacuadas de sus casas en el estado de
Río Grande de Sur en la frontera con
Argentina y Uruguay además las
autoridades están investigando si el
naufragio de un barco pesquero con ocho
tripulantes a bordo está relacionado con
este ciclón ocurrió en el vecino estado
de Santa Catarina cerca también del Sur
del país la Marina brasileña ha
comenzado las búsquedas pero de momento
no ha informado sobre ninguna muerte el
gobierno de Luis y la célula Silva
anunciado ayudas económicas primero para
las víctimas y posteriormente liberación
de más recursos para ayudar con la
reconstrucción y para superar este
momento duro
la avenida paulista de Sao Paulo fue el
escenario elegido por cientos de
personas que marcharon para pedir la
legalización de la marihuana actualmente
Brasil permite la venta y producción de
productos de cannabis pero las empresas
deben importar los ingredientes de base
se espera que el próximo año la Corte
Suprema de Justicia se pronuncie sobre
si empresas y agricultores podrán
plantar Cannabis en territorio brasileño
pasamos a Buenos Aires la capital
Argentina donde el elevado precio de los
alimentos ha llevado a muchos ciudadanos
a recoger alimentos de la basura de los
mercados que aún están en buenas
condiciones para ellos esta es la única
forma de abastecerse Alba Santana tiene
los detalles
tienen las manos y la vista entrenadas
limpia Benítez y Gladys Meza de 59 y 41
años sacan todos los días decenas de
kilogramos de frutas y verduras de la
basura del mercado central de Buenos
Aires como muchos otros en Argentina
intentan salvar a los alimentos que
todavía están en buen estado Yo gracias
a Dios tengo mi marido que él trabaja y
puedo comprar carne puedo comprar otra
cosa que sea alimento para mí Pero hay
gente que vive solamente de esta verdura
y es fuera de broma hay gente que lleva
solamente la verdura y con eso vive al
día naranjas que solo están manchadas de
tierra o tomates con apenas un golpe son
algunos de los alimentos que encuentran
entre la basura y es que en el país no
todo el mundo puede permitirse
comprarlos con una inflación al alza los
alimentos son de los productos más
afectados según cifras oficiales entre
junio de 2022 y mayo de 2000 a 23 su
precio aumentó en una 117%
pero para mí una vergüenza yo no
no me siento mal al contrario me siento
bien porque
lo tomo con un trabajo porque en
realidad estamos trabajando también nos
esforzamos para llevar todo a ver todas
las semanas estas ciudadanas recorren
unos 20 kilómetros para recoger la
comida que comparten también con sus
vecinos y con la que consiguen ahorrar
aproximadamente 30 dólares semanalmente
más de lo que muchos ganan a trabajando
en el norte de Costa Rica en las laderas
del volcán Tenorio y a orillas del río
Celeste los indígenas maleku reclaman su
parte de los beneficios del turismo en
sus tierras ancestrales que ellos
consideran sagradas también buscan
destacar el valor añadido de integrar a
su pueblo en el circuito ecoturístico le
ayuda en los amplía
en la remota cordillera de guanacaste un
pequeño lago y su cascada en el río
Celeste hacen Las Delicias diarias de un
millar de turistas captan con sus
cámaras al asombroso color que Revela la
luz solar de la mezcla de acidez cobre y
silicato de aluminio del suelo volcánico
esta maravilla natural se encuentra en
una zona indígena Malecón pero pocos
visitantes llegan hasta la aldea de
Palenque Margarita donde nuevos
empresarios en circuitos ecoturísticos
basados en su cosmovisión en los
territorios indígenas de Costa Rica casi
no hay trabajo usted no tiene trabajo
cómo va a sobrevivir Todo es dinero
ahora hace muchos años los indígenas no
ocupaban dinero entonces Ahora tenés que
sobrevivir la etnia es uno de los ocho
pueblos indígenas de Costa Rica que
juntos representan más del 2% de los 5.2
millones de habitantes del país a pesar
de haber firmado un convenio
internacional sobre el derecho de los
pueblos indígenas a la Tierra gobierno
costarricense se beneficia de los
ingresos del Parque Nacional sin tener
en cuenta los Malecón reclaman además el
río Celeste como parte de sus tierras
ancestrales usurpadas uno indígena no
comprende un no indígena no entiende no
sabe no sabe de esa espiritualidad de
esa cosmovisión propia de uno y algunos
algunos lo respetan y algunos no el río
y el volcán son lugares sagrados para
los malikum y su cosmovisión exige que
Los visitantes del parque se purifiquen
con cacao antes de entrar pero según los
indígenas nadie explica a los turistas
las dimensión espiritual de este lugar
más de 100.000 personas quedaron
maravilladas en Francia ante la
presencia del Cuauhtémoc el buque
escuela de la Armada mexicana El velero
se lució en un festival de barcos en el
puerto de ruán en el río sena Erika
olavarría con los detalles
[Música]
camiseta a rayas arneses alrededor del
cuerpo los marinos del buque escuela
mexicano Cuauhtémoc que por estos días
participa de la exposición de los
veleros más bellos del mundo en el
puerto de ruán en Francia se preparan
para el momento más importante del día
Gerardo es parte de la tripulación y con
más experiencia entrega Sus consejos a
los nuevos marinos que en pocos minutos
suben por los mástiles para hacer una
inspección del estado de las velas en
una arriesgada maniobra que cautiva a
quienes observan más que nada que tengan
la seguridad y la confianza de lo que
hacen para que pues el miedo como todo
es un poco de alerta entre los que
realizan esta Audaz tarea está Carolina
desde 1998 las mujeres entraron a La
Marina en México y en el Cuauhtémoc son
36 un poco más del 10% de la tripulación
sus padres sorprendidos con su elección
la acompañan cada vez que zarpa y recala
en México con mucho esfuerzo han venido
a Francia primera vez en el extranjero
es algo muy bonito para nosotros como
Paz nos sentimos muy orgullosos de
nuestra hija
14.000 personas por día han subido el
buque en Francia entre la acogida y las
demandas de selfie el evento es una
prueba más a la paciencia necesaria en
la formación de los marinos
es la visita obligada para ver barcos de
todos los países y este Es
verdaderamente el más bonito
vine a visitar este barco es
impresionante es uno de los más grandes
y la bandera mexicana atrae dan ganas de
venir a verlo
este Crucero del Cuauhtémoc recién
comienza tras la Habana Boston y ruán el
navío tiene aún cinco meses de travesía
por el Mediterráneo Inglaterra y el
Atlántico antes de volver a su base en
Acapulco El próximo cuatro de diciembre
finalizamos en México donde el famoso
pugilista Julio César Chávez impartió
una clase masiva de boxeo en el Zócalo
de la capital la leyenda mexicana
encabezó este evento al que acudieron
más de 30.000 personas de todas las
edades casi el doble de lo registrado en
esta misma sede del año pasado la
asistencia impuso un nuevo récord
guinness y el evento tuvo como objetivo
promover un estilo de vida saludable
además de difundir el ejercicio entre
los jóvenes para alejarlos de las drogas
y la violencia
es todo por el momento gracias por su
sintonía
[Música]